hi my name is Frank Schoenberg and I'm
the Wikimedia Foundation head of public
outreach the Wikimedia Foundation is the
organization behind Wikipedia the
Encyclopedia that everybody can add it
so I'm here today to tell you more about
Wikipedia and why you as a science
student should help Wikipedia to get
better let me start with a story about
what impact Wikipedia can have and this
is the story of Judy and Judy is the
mother of a 20 year old daughter from
Florida and Judy's daughter was
diagnosed with cancer at the age of two
so 18 years ago and at that time
Judy spend hours in medical libraries to
get more information about the specific
type of cancer that her daughter had and
18 years ago I mean she could find
little information about that specific
type of cancer and she couldn't
understand the medical terms she was
reading however her daughter survived
and then 12 years later Judy's daughter
was diagnosed with a different kind of
cancer and this time Judy used the
internet and Wikipedia she was armed
with knowledge about the disease its
causes and possible treatments and she
sent us an email
last year when we were in the middle of
our yearly fundraiser and Judy said
Wikipedia and the Internet has helped me
to gain a sense of control over the
uncontrollable and this is I think this
is a really a nice story to see how
Wikipedia impacts the life of people so
let me
tell you more about Wikipedia let me
give you some numbers and let me tell
you more about who's behind Wikipedia
who writes it let's start with the
numbers Wikipedia right now has 18
million articles in more than 260
languages and what I find really
impressive is that Wikipedia worldwide
all of these language versions get more
than 400 million unique visitors per
month and all the content of Wikipedia
is written by volunteers people like you
and me and there are more than hundred
thousands of volunteers who write
Wikipedia articles and they don't get
paid they just do it because they like
to learn and they like to teach others
and they like to share their knowledge
with others and they all believe in the
same vision that vision statement of the
Wikimedia Foundation that is we believe
that it's good to create a world where
every single human being on this planet
has access to the sum of all knowledge
and now back to the topic so I said I
want to give you some reasons why you
assigned students should help Wikipedia
to get better and I have three reasons
first of all if you write Wikipedia
articles you will learn a lot you will
learn to translate your special
knowledge to a general audience to an
audience of people like Judy who needs
information and who needs information
that is written in an easy-to-understand
language so you will also learn to to
write better you will
improve your writing skills because you
will interact with the community of
Wikipedia editors and the readers and
you will get feedback and people will
tell you hey there is something that I
didn't understand and maybe you can
write it a little bit in a different way
so that feedback is really good and then
also what you will learn is you will
improve your digital media literacy
skills because when you write Wikipedia
articles you will learn a lot about
Wikipedia culture and you will learn a
lot about what makes a good article and
why are some articles not as good as
other articles so you will learn a lot
about how the quality of Wikipedia how
Wikipedia gets created and that's one of
the big learnings so the second reason
why I think you as a science student
should help Wikipedia to get better is
you can give something back so I guess
that most of you use Wikipedia at least
one once a week and let me tell you
about me I use Wikipedia every day and
five years ago I decided I wanted to
give something back to Wikipedia so I
studied history and five years ago I
started to improve history articles on
Wikipedia and that gives me a good
feeling because I'm taking information
from Wikipedia every day I learned a lot
I enjoy reading Wikipedia articles so I
give something back
so the third reason why I think you as a
science student should help Wikipedia to
get better is that huge audience that
Wikipedia has imagined the cancer
article on the English Wikipedia gets
more than 200 and thousand views per
month
isn't that amazing so many views I
remember when I wrote
articles for scientific journals I got
maybe I got 20 years or so but on
Wikipedia my articles get or read much
more people and this is a great thing so
imagine you would help to make the
cancer article better and you would get
more than 200,000 views per month
wouldn't that be great so here's the
three reasons again you will learn a lot
you can give something back to Wikipedia
and you will write for a huge audience
and now there are many ways you can help
Wikipedia to get better you can just
take a look at an article and look at
the language and maybe you want to copy
edit it it's very easy you just click on
the edit button and you can start copy
editing and then you click Save and
everything is done and you've helped
Wikipedia to get better
you can also fact check Wikipedia
articles existing Wikipedia articles or
you can upload pictures or you could
even start a new Wikipedia article and
it's really easy go to Wikipedia click
on the edit button and then start
editing and you can help people like
Judy to find the information that they
need thank you very much
you